jean-marie et
quelle est la plus grosse connerie que
tu fntv
je crois que j'ai fait
pipi d'un bénitier de la petite chapelle
j'étais en pensionnat à l'âge de 14 ans
ça ça doit comme comme en réponse pas du
tout
quelle est la plus grosse connerie que
tu fais dans ta vie celle que tu as fait
le plus
alors la plus grosse connerie que je
regrette je dire exactement ce que c'est
c'est 2
c'est de ne pas avoir
démarrer
mes conneries assez tôt si tu m'aimes
parce que si je les avais démarré plus
tôt oui conneries j'aurais pu montrer ça
mes parents et
et malheureusement ils sont plus là je
peux pas leur montrer et pour moi ça
c'est une grosse connerie j'attends lui
trente ans avant de partir et mon parent
a été fier de moi associé c'est ma plus
grosse connerie ggp a été précoce
j'étais vraiment retardataires
le problème de cette connerie c'est que
tu peux pas la racheter
je sais pas c'est ça c'est possible
quand même peut-être que peut-être que
si ça marche après ce que je crois s'il
n'a pas qu'une seule vie je crois que ça
doit marcher ses doigts ça va être vu
quand même facile à tu crois qu'ils
voient à redon je crois qu'il doit
réussir petite voix paris oui je crois
qu'il me voit et puis je crois que ton
le fait si on le fait pour quand même je
crois que ça marche quand même
tu crois donc qu'il ya une vie ailleurs
tu pourras l'au delà absolument comment
ne pas croire qu' il ya une autre vie
après la vie en possède pas la vie en
cela transmet la preuve qu'elle ne meure
pas et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu